jack-jack China has a minor role in The
Incredibles if people bought the DVD or
the blu-ray they got to see a short
called Jack Jack Attack that kind of
shows what he was doing with the
babysitter while the rest of the family
was going through the movie and so
that's an interesting thing you know
kind of what the t-shirt is here
well symbol of Jack Jack's multiple
powers but the interesting thing is the
family doesn't know anything about those
powers they when the babysitter saw that
the babysitter had her mind erased the
the you know he changes up by the jet
but they that's far away and they don't
see it and he's normal by the time he
lands on the ground so this film they
start to discover that he has these
powers and so it's a it's an interesting
kind of fun situation to explore you
know it's basically the first time all
of the the voice cast has been together
on stage at once there have been various
combinations that have happened but it
hasn't all been at once so we had Craig
T Nelson who plays mr. incredible we
have Holly Hunter who does the voice of
Helen or Elastigirl
we had Sam Jackson who does lucious best
also known as Frozone and Sarah Vowell
who did violet and we have a newcomer
named Huck Milner who does the voice of
- well I think you know the thing that
was really exciting for all of us is
that is that Incredibles part 2 was
being created and directed by Brad
braggart so that was kind of the seal of
okay of excellence that this movie is
going to reach for places the only Brad
can kind of you know navigate and it has
been incredibly fun to work with him you
know yeah and of course this is our
first time that we've all been together
ever we have never been together until
today so that's amazing well I you know
I don't really have any thing to compare
it to because it is incomparable this
environment
in the fervent enthusiasm that thousands
of people have that are actually
physically out there coming at you if
it's listen it is lovely it's always
amazing to be part of something that you
know people really really like and for
years and years and years everybody's
gone so what are you going to do it when
you're going to do it what is it going
to happen when's it going to happen and
you know it's wonderful and I was wow I
don't know how to describe the first day
I showed up in the studio's kind of like
yeah so you know getting it done and
getting back in there like really
wonderful and seeing Brad and all the
people so I'm really anxious to see the
film and to enjoy it with an audience I
have the same reaction so yes yeah it's
kind of jaw-dropping and I think that's
what they were sitting there doing
because we know things about Jack Jack
that you know the family doesn't know
and there are things that we still don't
know about him so to watch him do
different things is going to be a
process of discovery and he's even more
incredible than everybody else are you
know it's different being in a studio
and being on set and looking at people
that are bigger than you and have
superpowers you know at least in this
one I have Howard yeah and when I'm Nick
Fury I'm just kind of the only guys in
the movie that doesn't really have power
I'm just kind of angry when anger can be
a power we just met a couple of hours
ago we just met a couple of hours ago
but I feel like we're already like
cementing the sibling rivalry
so you she's the grumpy one on the happy
one yeah yeah you're the happy one for
now this is are you I thought it was
really funny but before I thought just
as a sketch I only got in the sketch it
was so funny because I like how
Jack Jack is fighting a raccoon
the idea itself is funny and then the
execution you know like some of the
sounds and just watching you kind of
feel a little bad for the raccoon he
sort of you know I feel bad from again
you do at the end you like Jack Jack has
power like what are we to do it's great
to see everybody you know the cast
because I don't think we've been
together in one room I don't know we
certainly Sam and I recorded together
but I haven't seen Ben with Holly so and
and violet so it was great we kind of
heard rumors but that had been happening
for a while and you know he just
shoulders this you just let it go I'm
not sure but then you know what happened
and you're excited you know Brad has
done such a good job on the story and
John Walker and it it's like it's a lot
of fun and yeah I think it's going to be
great
you